well during this time of year we see a
lot of cars stranded on the side of the
freeway maybe they had a tire blow out a
battery the car is just overheating the
Nevada Department of Transportation is
preparing for what may be ahead in these
coming hot days the news now weather
reporter Mary Jane beliesza wrote along
with ndot's freeway service Patrol with
how they're helping drivers get back on
the road
if I see something I can go get it and
uh it's it's full of excitement every
day Steven San Filippo is an ndot Las
Vegas Freeway Patrol supervisor
from jumper cables to specialty tools
he's equipped to help any stranded
motorist people get impatient because of
the Heat and you get a lot of crashes
his route stretches from the I-15 along
Craig to St Rose Parkway not only is he
helping people get off the freeway
safely but he's braving the heat too
Sanfilippo always stays cool by wearing
long sleeves and hydrating thank you so
much even offering water to those stuck
answering up to 15 calls a day he's seen
his fair share of heat related car
troubles
when a vehicle overheats I carry two
five gallon jugs and they don't have any
fluids in their cooling system he's been
on the
bed on the years and knows these roads
inside and out they're so grateful
especially when we get them off the
freeway because a lot of times they're
panicking like Ashley Marone who is on
her way to work this morning when her
car broke down I was a little dilemma I
had to pull it over because it was
overheating and what the heat too it's
not even going to help it much at all
it's just going to keep overheating more
Marone said no one even stopped to help
it only took San Filippo 10 minutes to
get her back on the road he just was a
real angel right now I'd be really stuck
I don't know how I'm gonna get it home
or how I'm going to get it to her San
felipo says it's moments like these that
makes the job worthwhile I enjoy what I
do I enjoy helping people every day